hi guys this nope no no no hi guys my
name is Kara chambers and I'm Cody
Melton and this is Tamara's never know
and this is Tamra just saw and Cody also
just saw two as well
furiously haters gonna face same speech
it was great it's faster furious number
eight which I thought was the end of end
of them
no I already I believe have my Anton
scheduled already according to Vin
Diesel's IMDB right I'm glad he's
getting out there me too
mingling keeping it fresh making friends
that aren't ridic or XXX related so I
have went into this having never seen
one other such a serious movie and you
and I watched every single one of them
in the last 24 hours I have slept very
little but let me tell you it was a ride
I slept a lot and I still thought it was
a pretty good read this movie was just
so much flippin fun it's that kind of
action where it's so good you're
laughing because you're just having such
a good time this is also one of the
moments where the ensemble really really
works well Fast Five was very similar to
this you speak a lot to the very recent
movies I've watched where they've all
gotten really comfortable and you can
tell that they're kind of having fun
with each other like there was some
moments on camera that felt like they
could have been ripped or improvised
where they were joking around with each
other
yeah I definitely would believe that
yeah thinking about kind of a dialogue
and I had I think some of the lines were
really cheesy and and awful um but in a
way that's like it's cool
it's kind of the franchise right well
which I've experienced over time the
franchise like post over time over a day
look that was a day that's cause you
post Fast Five it's definitely more of
the franchise when they really kind of I
think that's when they hit their stride
it's definitely like the new Fast and
Furious especially with the rock
involved is this more it's that rock
energy I really think the rock brings
that kind of energy to what he does
which is that kind of like cool badass
but like funny
funny he does by far my favorite
character yeah he had the best lines
they gave him all the like comedic off
sides like at one point he braked out of
handcuffs I think you got the good
entered like a high-security prison and
you just break that I inked up someone
mentions his daughter it's like a hell
yes you did right do it do it so going
into this you were like oh Kurt
Russell's in this Seville I was like I
don't like Kurt Russell we could like
really that's odd
okay I he'll does walk her like two days
ago for the reviewer don't like him and
then I was watching and it was something
was wrong in the midst of my stomach I
knew something is wrong and I could be
like I was really really Oh Cody
oh no it's not Kurt Russell it's Jeff
Bridges the custard could did yours just
keep watching
that was a bigger revelation and when
Lettie turned out not to be dead took me
on the movie for a bit so that's one of
my complaints about the fate of furious
is that Tamra encourages good views I
texted ugh because I had told ugh that
and you're like that's so weird but I
love him so that was a great revelation
for me I do indeed Russell has been
saved
yeah see like you're as well now we have
to discuss Jeff Bridges but well that's
a whole other matter doesn't do it for
me yeah he said he seems like a John
Wayne wannabe and I was like have you
only seen him in tombstone
thank you like again I still think that
Kurt Russell is a not wanna be I didn't
want to be I said he's like a person
again in person he's got a twinge of a
John Wayne I think it's just to be
squinty and masculine no no you have you
seen Big Trouble in Little China know
the whole tiny Don is like pre podcast
era like trucks walkie talkies he's like
this alright guys here we go
we're gonna go do this my name's Cooper
absolute look at that a CB radio and
they still have that attracted for
communication I believe you look Vader's
gonna face famous gonna face but I
forgot has the franchise in general what
got a little got a little tiring kind of
and so I was coming into this like right
I mean not even just because I want to
develop very quickly but you know I'm
Sheila I think we yeah I was honest
coming into this like I don't know where
that word baton if you're frozen furious
is going to come from because seven felt
so kind of final with Brian going off
and I've been hearing whispers in the
wind that it was not gonna it was gonna
fall a little short because of the fact
that there wasn't that DOM and Brian
dynamic I think I think it I think it
replaces that with the greater crew a
lot better I think it's because of that
they lean heavier on the dynamic with
the crew I think this is a great story
to have right after Brian leaves the
only salt I'll say and I don't know if
you agree with me on this one is venom
in the beginning it really feels kind of
like two different movies there's like
the rock Jason Statham buddy cop movie
and then there's the Dom trying to get
his family together you know betrayal
movie but they come together at the end
really well and I hadn't seen the other
movie so it's probably like but it's
like establishes who is who and like
establishes the rock is going to be this
funny guy who was like this and Jason
Statham is going to go along with it so
like I don't know I ain't brought any
very end like together 'no so so nicely
done that since wasn't real i will say
though the movie was such a blast it was
two hours and forty minutes which i was
like no i know it was fun for the first
two hours super fun super into it didn't
feel long it really lasts for is 40
minutes we just like the whole time I
was just like stressed and my mouth was
open and I was just like yeah at the end
of the movie we were we were both
freaking out there were moments where
you're just like oh my god yes like that
comeback like that's happening this is
great I just like to crap another's
class is yeah you know sometimes you
just want to clap he said it was two
hours and forty minutes long but it
really felt like under 10 seconds that's
a fast and furious reference because we
run a quarter mile and race you want to
knock you so far down your throat that
you're going on just dig a toothbrush of
your ass two brushes and I have to laugh
at a coffee accent you would say that
some of the people had grown a lot in
the first
Luda Luda is a lot better from the
second one too fast and too fast lute is
terrible
I love Luda got way better at acting so
good job hurt on your head - you told
her I thought it was excellent in it I
thought the acting on as a whole was so
fun so great there were definitely
moments of weakness of course my c4 like
a non-stop action thriller I was super
into the acting Helen Mirren I'm a
sudden Miriam Helen Miriam within this I
mean they cast the perfect infant good
job central casting I mean it does just
look like a tiny Vin Diesel did you
really just miss baby groups oh my gosh
somebody has to do that to be a thing
big room uber and then Vin Diesel and
baby diesels baby people than a right
Ken diesel Brian diesel yeah that's
right I was a good that was a good nada
see and I was kind of expecting him to
be named Brian but that was nice I say
this a lot whenever someone's like you
sure movie I'm like ah for sure I'll
totally watch that movie and I'm not
going to definitely not gonna watch a
movie but I will say I really think that
I want to love to cook these films well
you got twenty forever I think it's
hilarious and I watched this on the
eights because I also saw the eight
Harry Potter was the first Harry Potter
movie ever saw I don't know think it's a
really good system you can really watch
this is the eighth of any franchise
whatsoever so we get to that point I'll
see your Dan movie I mean one of my
negatives which is a weird negative to
have about the eighth movie in a
franchise like it's not anybody else's
fault but like I it was one of those
movies where if you hadn't seen the
other movies I don't know what you read
on it actually so I'm really curious
about your take on it because it's like
there were so many folded in elements
from previous movies I mean it's not
even like you had to have watched from
five you have to avoid watched from the
very beginning if not at the least fat
like too fast to period to really get it
I feel like one if you're seeing it at
the eighth film that's a first bathroom
Furious films fu camera with this I
would have seen the things the
characters
I didn't know being referenced in
everything like obviously cool callback
great I don't know what it is but
awesome it's very late because the movie
is very long but it's enjoyable yeah no
fun yeah it's really fun and furious
that's in the fury is nice sudden fury
welcomes us we other toddler gets like
one of those like battery operated cars
you know like little diesel little
beetle gets a little car and then he's
like whip it around and what cars make
it fast in the Furious parity please
make that happen please is it cars just
a facet of your is parity know already
no not another day there's not anything
coming out this month April the bad
month salute yeah what is next week I
had mono
I have leap question mark in my dry yeah
well I don't know what we think I don't
think we could find anything better
oh is the ballerina one yeah oh all
right get ready I'm taking tap right now
oh you do that I can't do dance
looks like we're from two different
worlds Tamara we can yes whoo we're such
friends
[Music]